♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE ARE COMING TO YOU LIVE,
RIVERSIDE, FROM KYOTO, JAPAN.
WE DO NOT MAKE IT BACK FROM OUR
LIVE CAMERA LOCATION YESTERDAY.
WE HAD QUITE A JOURNEY.
WE ALL THROW TO YOU THROUGHOUT
THE HOUR.
WE'LL BE INTERVIEWING THE
PRESIDENT IN JAPAN HERE FOR THE
G20.
BACK IN THE NATIVE LAND, THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WENT COMPLETELY
INSANE YESTERDAY.
IT'S BEEN HAPPENING FOR A WHILE
OF COURSE.
INSANITY IS A PROCESS.
BUT LAST NIGHT, THE FIRST
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY DEBATE OF THE
2,020 SEASON, THEY MADE IT
OFFICIAL.
ELITE DEMOCRATS HAVE PERMANENTLY
BROKEN WITH REALITY.
THEY NO LONGER CARE ABOUT WHAT
IS TRUE, WHAT IS POSSIBLE.
EVEN ONCE WE.
THEY LIVE IN A KIND OF DREAM
STATE, I PLACE A FANTASY,
PUNCTUATED BY
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS.
WATCH AS JULIAN CASTRO, KEEP IN
MIND, HE WAS AN ACTUAL CABINET
SECRETARY IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, ONLY A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO, WATCH AS
JULIAN CASTRO EXPLAINS THAT MEN
WHO GET PREGNANT HAVE A MORAL
RIGHT TO TAXPAYER-FUNDED
ABORTIONS.
NOT JOKING.
WATCH.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE ONLY IN
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM.
I BELIEVE IN REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT JUST
BECAUSE A WOMAN OR, LET'S ALSO
NOT FORGET SOMEONE IN THE TRANS
COMMUNITY, A TRANS FEMALE --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
IT DOES NOT MEAN THEY SHOULD NOT
HAVE THE RIGHT TO EXERCISE THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
>> Tucker: AND SO THEY
CHEERED.
THE HOLD PLATE EMPIRE LIBERALISM
IN FULL FLOWER.
WHO EXACTLY IS A CONSTITUENCY
FOR CASTRO'S IDEA?
MEN DRESSED AS WOMEN WHO GET
PREGNANT.
THAT IS A CONSTITUENCY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE ARE
PRECISELY ZERO PEOPLE ON PLANET
EARTH WHO FIT THAT DESCRIPTION.
NOT A SINGLE PERSON, ACTUALLY.
THERE NEVER HAVE BEEN ANY PEOPLE
LIKE THAT.
THERE NEVER WILL BE ANY PEOPLE
WHY?
BECAUSE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
BIOLOGICAL MEN CANNOT GET
PREGNANT.
PRETENDING OTHERWISE IS LUNACY.
AT THE VERY DEFINITION OF LUNACY
AT THE VERY DEFINITION OF LUNAC.
BUT JULIAN CASTRO DOESN'T CARE.
TAXPAYER-FUNDED TRANSGENDER
ABORTION SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING
THAT ALL GOOD PROGRESSIVES
SHOULD SUPPORT.
SO CASTRO FERVENTLY DOES.
AND CRITICALLY, HE KNOWS THAT
NOBODY IN THE ROOM WHILE
DIFFERENT SCIENCE OR PAUSE TO
ASK THEM, WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
I CAN'T SAY A WORD.
THEY ARE TO DID INTIMIDATED.
THEY KNOW HR IS WATCHING.
SO THEY NOD LIKE MONKEYS AS OF
EVERYTHING HE IS SAYING IS
COMPLETELY SANE.
GOOD POINT, MR. SECRETARY PERRY
TRANS FEMALE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
PAY FOR THEIR OWN ABORTIONS.
THAT'S RACIST."
THE WHOLE THING WAS A CARTOON,
OR A NOVEL.
IT WENT ON LIKE THIS ALL NIGHT.
HERE FOR EXAMPLE IS
JULIAN CASTRO AGREEING WITH
ELIZABETH WARREN THAT IT
SHOULDN'T BE ILLEGAL FOR
FOREIGNERS TO BREAK OUR LAWS.
WATCH.
>> WHEN SOMEBODY COMES ACROSS
THE BORDER, NOT DECRIMINALIZE
DESPERATION, BUT TREAT THAT IS A
CIVIL VIOLATION.
>> Tucker: CRIMINALIZE
DESPERATION.
YOU THOUGHT THIS WAS YOUR
COUNTRY.
JUST BECAUSE, LIKE YOUR
ANCESTORS, YOU WERE BORN HERE,
JUST BECAUSE YOU MAY HAVE YOUR
INCOME TO THE GOVERNMENT TO KEEP
THE WHOLE THING GOING, YOU
THOUGHT IT WAS YOUR COUNTRY.
THINK AGAIN, RACIST.
AMERICA BELONGS TO THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
YOUR JOB IS TO SHUT UP AND PAY
FOR IT.
COMPLAIN AND WILL PUNISH YOU.
BILL de BLASIO OFTEN MAKES
THAT POINT, AND de BLASIO, THE
SINGLE WORST MAYOR IN THE 400
YEAR HISTORY OF NEW YORK CITY.
THAT IS IMPRESSIVE.
BUT HOW DID HE WIND UP ON A
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE STAGE LAST
NIGHT?
GOD KNOWS.
MAYBE HE ILLEGALLY IMMIGRATED
THERE.
DOESN'T MATTER.
HE WAS THERE.
ONCE HE HAD THE MIC, de BLASIO
PROMISED TO SEIZE YOUR MONEY AND
GIVE IT TO HIS SUPPORTERS, WHO
HE EXPLAINED DESERVE IT MUCH
MORE THAN YOU DO.
>> YES, WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
FOR 70% TAX RATE ON THE WEALTHY.
WE ARE FOLK SAY THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY, I SAY TO THEM
EVERY SINGLE TIME, THERE'S
PLENTY OF MONEY IN THIS WORLD,
PLENTY OF MONEY IN THIS COUNTRY,
IT'S JUST IN THE WRONG HANDS.
>> GOT IT?
WE'VE GOT THE POWER.
SOON WE'LL HAVE ALL THE GUNS,
AND WE ARE COMING FOR YOUR STUF
STUFF.
THAT WAS A MAJOR THEME OF LAST
NIGHT.
IN CASE ANYONE WAS DEAD, THE TWO
BRIGHTEST CANDIDATES
ON STAGE DECIDED TO REPEAT THE
POINT AND STILTED SPANISH.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
GOT THAT, GRINGO?
YOU CAN ADD THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
OF THE LONGER I THINK OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CONSIDERS
RACIST.
HOW LONG BEFORE YOU ARE BANNED
FROM SPEAKING AT?
THINK I'M JOKING, RIGHT?
BETTER WANT TO LEARN AS MANUAL
IF YOU WANT TO KNOCK YOUR
GRANDKIDS.
IT'S A BRAND-NEW WORLD.
SOME OF THE LEAST IMPRESSIVE
PEOPLE IN AMERICA ARE MAKING THE
RULES.
IF YOU ARE EXCITED FOR IT.
AT LEAST MEN WILL BE ABLE TO GET
FREE ABORTIONS.
EVEN WHEN THEY WEREN'T SPEAKING
SPANISH, WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE GOOD
IT WAS TYPICALLY AN EFFORT TO
ONE UP ANOTHER ON
IMMIGRATION.
WHO THE REMARKS MARSH RADICAL.
WATCH THIS.
>> I'M STILL TALKING ABOUT
EVERYTHING --
>> WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT ONE
SMALL PART OF US.
I'M TALKING ABOUT IN A
COMPREHENSIVE REWRITE OF OUR
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE --
>> ALL OUR LAWS --
>> MILLIONS OF FOLKS, A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT ARE COMING ARE NOT
SEEKING ASYLUM.
>> Tucker: WOUND UP.
FOX THAT HENRY WAS IN MIAMI LAST
NIGHT FOR THE DEBATE.
HE JOINED US THIS EVENING.
WE ARE ALWAYS GLAD TO HAVE HIM.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, ED.
HOW WAS IT?
>> TUCKER, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
AMAZING.
ROUND TWO COMING UP.
PRETTY INTERESTING, ONE OF THE
JUICIEST PARTS OF THE STORY IS
NOT TOO LONG AGO JULIAN CASTRO
HIMSELF SAID THE BORDER CRISIS
WAS B.S.
THAT IS WHAT HE TOLD CNN.
NOW HE'S TRYING TO BREAK OUT OF
THE PACK BY BEATING UP ON THE
PRESIDENT, SO HE SAYING JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
IT IS SUCH A CRISIS, HE SAID, WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING RADICAL.
THE WORD USED A MOMENT AGO, SO
RADICAL THE DEMOCRAT
AMY KLOBUCHAR SAID TO HIM IN
TIMEOUT.
SHE SAID SHE WILL LOOK AT
DECRIMINALIZING ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS, BUT SAID, THE REAL
FOCUS SHOULD BE GOING AFTER
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS WHO ARE
HURTING WOMEN AND CHILDREN AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE "VIOLATING THE
LAW" WHICH REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT HAS HAD FOUR WEEKS,
NOT FOUR YEARS.
FUNNY BECAUSE THE OTHER BIG
DEMOCRATS ON STAGE TONIGHT, FOR
PART TWO, HAVE ALSO FLIPPED
RIGHT KAMALA HARRIS ARE DEALING
WITH ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION WAS A
"DISTRACTION FROM THE REAL
ISSUE."
BERNIE SANDERS SAID THERE WAS NO
CRISIS.
NOT A GOOD LUCK WHEN
APPREHENSIONS OF THE BORDER ARE
UP 623% FROM 2017.
THEN THERE'S BILL de BLASIO,
YOU MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO,
PUSHING THAT 70% TAX RATE FOR
THE REST.
HE KNOWS WITH ONE RUN FURTHER.
THEY RAISE THEIR HANDS IN FAVOR
OF ENDING PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE ALTOGETHER.
FOR MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
DEMOCRAT JOHN DELANEY, ON THE
STAGE LAST NIGHT, TOLD ME AFTER,
HE THINKS THAT IS POLITICAL
SUICIDE FOR HIS PARTY.
ONE OF THE MANY REASONS WHILE
THE REAL WILL NEVER BE USED TWO
DEBATES, SECOND ONE STARTING
SOON, MAY BE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: ED HENRY,
THANK YOU.
BE INTERESTING WHAT LABOR UNIONS
SHOULD THINK WE SPENT 100 YEARS
NEGOTIATING PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE, WHAT THEY WILL SAY AO
INSURANCE, WHAT THEY WILL SAY AT
INSURANCE, WHAT THEY WILL SAY AA
INSURANCE, WHAT THEY WILL SAY A.
NBC BROUGHT FIVE SEPARATE
MODERATORS TO LAST NIGHT'S
DEBATE, ALMOST ALL OF THEM
SHILLS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
TOGETHER THEY SPENT, NOT
SURPRISED WHEN, MOST OF THE TIME
TALKING SOFTBALL QUESTIONS TO
THE CANDIDATES, QUESTIONS
INTENDED TO DRAG OUT THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION HYSTERIA.
HERE IS THE SELECTION.
>> WE SAW THAT IMAGE TODAY THAT
BROKE OUR HEARTS, AND THEY HAD
NAMES.
IF YOU WERE PRESIDENT TODAY,
WHAT WOULD YOU SPECIFICALLY DO?
>> DO YOU HAVE A PLAN TO DEAL
WITH MITCH McCONNELL IF THE
HOUSE CHOOSES NOT TO IMPEACH?
>> AS PRESIDENT, WOULD YOU DO
ANYTHING TO ADDRESS THE
POTENTIAL CRIMES THAT WERE
OUTLINED IN MR. MUELLER'S
REPORT?
>> NO U.S. PRESIDENT HAS EVER
BEEN PROSECUTED FOR CRIMES AFTER
LEAVING OFFICE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD OR SHOULD
BE THE FIRST?
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
'S TRUMP BAD?
"HE'S BAD."
LOTS OF SOFTBALLS.
YET, STILL, NO MATTER HOW EASY
THE QUESTIONS, MOST PEOPLE SEEM
TO AGREE THAT FORMER CONGRESSMAN
BETO O'ROURKE
BECLOWNED
HIMSELF.
AFTER THE DEBATE, ONE OF US
ANCHOR SAID THAT HE WAS NOT
BEING TAKEN SERIOUS ENOUGH.
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING THAT
THERE IS A SNACK WITH THE WAY
YOU ARE TREATED, BY THE BY THE
MEDIA, OR THE OTHER DEMOCRATS ON
STAGE.
I WONDER -- THAT IS WHAT IT
LOOKED LIKE TO ME AS SOMEONE
ROOTING FOR -- ROOTING FOR
EVERYBODY.
A BIG FIELD HELPS ALL OF US,
CERTAINLY MORE FUN TO COVER BUT
YOU WERE SINGLED OUT, YOU WERE
TARGETED, YOU ARE ATTACKED AND I
WONDER WHAT THAT IS LIKE.
>> Tucker: SEE YOU ARE A
BLUSHING FAN GIRL.
OKAY, SHOULD YOU ADMIT THAT THE
PUBLIC ON LIVE TV?
PROBABLY NOT.
NO MATTER HOW IMPRESSED SHE WAS
BY BETO O'ROURKE, HE IS STILL
MORE IMPRESSED BY HIMSELF.
WATCH THIS.